Still sexual because of society,
because of,
that's why women think
of women as being sexual.
It's like women will make out
with women and party with women,
and part of it is because
they think that guys like it.
But also part of it is because in our
society that it has been deemed that women
are more sexual,
they're more sex objects.
They use them to sell watches
and cars and shit like that.
It's like it's more natural and accepted.
So I think a gay guy would have way less
problems fucking a straight girl than a
straight guy would have fucking a gay guy.
You know what I mean?
Okay.
So if you said to a guy,
guy,
fuck a girl,
he probably do it quicker than a Hetero
guy would fuck another guy in the ass.
Even though he'd fuck
is going on the last,
the Hetero guy was in prison.
Let's then it's alive.
Different Ball because guys,
guys are saying,
I'm not gay,
but just made it put my cooking something.
Yeah,
that's a strange thing,
isn't it?
How much humans adapt?
They adapt so much that
straight people become gay.
While they're in jail to jail.
I've become the best master
bedroom on the planet.
I'll fucking get artwork.
I saw a shank that someone
made at a toilet paper.
They don't know exactly
how the dude did this,
but he somehow or another created a shank
and use something to harden to toilet
paper,
shank dues.
The weirdest thing ever.
I mean just you think about
human ingenuity and one
of the things about prison
is that these guys are forced to
adapt and survive and you know,
and kind of use their ingenuity.
Here's their creativity and
create things that no one,
that's why they develop
tattoo needles with,
you know,
at a take pens and they
get the ink and they,
they'll burn things and use the,
the,
the milk.
They'll like make ink.
They make their own ink out of
burning plastic and burning paper.
And then they figured out how to make
some sort of a machine with a battery.
And it's really kind of amazing some of
the things that people had done in jail.
But this was one of the weirdest man.
The guy made a weapon out of toilet paper.
Someone with it or don't they found it?
I think they found it,
but they don't.
They don't know what the fuck this
guy did to make the toilet paper hard.
But you know,
he had made it to the point
where it was like plaster.
Fuck.
It was like,
he like he had developed a shank and
actual shank out of toilet paper.
Man,
it's one plus on everyone.
I end up fucking imprisonment.
I would not survive.
It's a dark fucking world man.
I know a dude who just got
out of this guy warm machine,
you know,
warming.
So one machine can be nice guy.
Writer's room twitting.
You ask him where you were playing.
Yeah,
he got a,
he got in some shit on Twitter.
It wasn't a pretty experienced.
It's not,
it's horrible.
And that's just,
that's just small time shit
that's just doing a year.
You know,
you watch those locked down shows,
we'll get to scary man.
There's windows in
Jersey for strike force.
I remember driving back to the airport.
I'm not sure what was
Newark or JFK or whatever,
but on the way to the airport
actually we you drove,
you drove past a prison
yard and in Australia,
like in Melbourne we have one prison.
We have bough in prison now,
which is in the country.
It's like out of Melbourne.
We used to have a um,
uh,
a one right in the heart of
the city but now it's out.
So I'm not used to saint prisoners and
like we drove past a prison yard and like
as you driving past the fucking fence
to the prisoners right there with
prisoners walking around
in fucking orange.
And even though I was in a
cab or sort of shit myself,
just not used to sing
that being from Australia,
I'm like prisoners right there,
right near the road.
I can see them walking around.
The president is very kick,
big,
big sign.
The numbers of people in prisons,
a big sign that this society is a mess.
That's if you ever wanted like some real
hardcore evidence as to how much of a
mess I society is.
Our prison numbers are huge.
More people are in prep,
more black banner in prison
right now then wherever.
Slaves.
Really?
Yeah,
I believe so.
I think that's true though.
Um,
and you know,
the,
just the sheer numbers,
there's millions of people.
There's more people in jail in America,
then all of China.
And that's incredible.
When you consider China
has over a billion people,
there's way more people in jail here.
Fuck.
We have more people in jail
than several countries.
Like if you add up a bunch of
different countries in a row,
we have more putting more
people in jail than them.
Fuck,
that is amazing.
Well,
they make money off of it.
That's the sickest part about our jail
system is that we have private business,
the Giles Beta,
very crammed and they're building
more of them all the time and they're
arresting people and more and
more silly shit all the time.
Well,
what's the,
um,
the one in San Fran.
San Quintin.
Yeah.
So we did a tour in San Francisco a few
days ago and that the two of God pointy
at San Quintin and he said,
it looks like there
might be a possibility.
It's going to be sold soon.
Prison's going to be sold.
San Quentin prison,
the the land is going to,
the prison is going to close down.
They'll like had to prison somewhere
else and terrible down and build luck.
San Quintin estate,
putting houses on it.
I San Quintin is at the moment.
He said it's a really good
chance of that happening.
Who the fuck would want to live
over all that gay rape dude,
it is in Melbourne and
same Pinch Ridge Child.
So I was trying to think
of before was in Coburg,
which is in Melbourne's
inner northern suburbs,
which has become quite a
trendy spot at that moment.
Used to be just the big
ethnic spot still is,
but now a trendy spot and that's where
Pinterest prison was located and years
ago they tore down pantry.
Jen,
now it's apartments.
Don't they remember if Poulter guys,
they build those houses over the Indian
burial grounds and then the ghost to the
Indians came and fucked everybody up.
You know,
I'd buy an apartment of goals of
all the shakings and all that.
Just all of them at the
four biggest ones on men.
If you ever get to Melbourne,
I'll take you to the old Melbourne jail,
which is still spelt J I o.
L the old way when Ned Kelly
and most famous my skull.
Yeah,
Gil.
The old English spelling is G.
So old Melbourne jail.
Pronounced pronounced Gerald though.
Might just spelling goal though.
No,
Miss Aol and C o.
L.
E.
So gale,
but pronounced Jr,
but it's the old spelling,
the old English style for jail
and old Melbourne Giles way.
Ned Kelly,
who's the most famous
criminal of all time.
You know what I'm saying?
Movies on him.
He was the dude that wore
like a fucking nightmare.
I thought chopper was
the most short reads,
the most popular at the moment.
He's off the,
you know,
he's away.
The last 10 years or so since
Eric Bana did the movie.
That was a great movie.
A fantastic fucking Eric Bender rocks,
man.
He's a bad motherfucker.
A bonafide celebrity now in Australia.
He's good.
I liked that a comedian who does
the impressions of him hard enough.
Fuck out.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Doing the weather and that talking a
little about these hot enough fuck out.
You know,
the whole criminal thing in,
uh,
in Melbourne at the moment
is really being glorified,
especially at our mobsters because
there's this underbelly TV series,
which I think is hit America
on one of the networks,
but underbelly is intellect.
It's fourth season.
So now,
and it's a,
it started off being about the,
uh,
the Melbourne underworld,
the Italian mobs and the,
you know,
the Aussie sort of mobs that were
warring with each other over the last 15
years.
And there's only a few of them left now.
They ended up mostly
killing each other off,
but I'm just a news Piper's a full of it.
An underbelly series is right.
It's so high in Australia.
There's that.
So it,
it's a nation we've with,
with mobsters,
they become like celebrities.
Exactly.
Then it becomes more popular.
Yup.
Yeah.
They have mob wives here.
Have you ever seen this mob?
I'll sort of have to set a mob wives.
So it was fucking monsters.
Yeah.
It's just so crazy.
There's one,
the fat one who's by herself
and her husband left her,
you know the divorce,
but she's like a big star of it and she's
always screaming and when there's less
on TV,
she's smoking cigarettes and crying
and screaming and you're like,
oh,
this monster.
If these women end up with these guys,
you know,
guys,
chicks that go to prison,
they flipped the fuck guys in prison and
like have relationships with dude's in
prison.
Like has a woman get to that point?
They love the strong,
like the the s w what would it represents?
You know,
they like going into a restaurant.
Everybody respects them.
They like the fact that people pick up
the tab because they're afraid of these
people.
The two fucking fucking,
yeah,
yeah.
There's,
there's something about it.
It's like,
you know what I mean?
It goes back to the godfather movies.
It goes back to the John
Gadi thing in New York.
It's like there's this weird sort of a
romantic thing of knowing someone that's
in the Mafia.
People of,
we had finished his man.
I'm watching this organized
crime thing is a deep thing.
I grew up in Boston and
it was Whitey Bulger.
That guy who just got busted.
He was on the run for like 16 years,
but he ran the Irish mob and
you know there was a lot of,
I were trained with a lot
of Whitey Bulger's hit men.
Did you ever use to
have that Boston accent?
Yeah,
I had that for awhile.
that's cool.
Exit Man.
That was pretty decent.
I love it.
It's cool.
Whenever I see a movie,
so your boss Doug Guy and you
want to be look like a Douche bag.
It's a great accent.
I love,
I love the sound of the pack.
Your fucking car had the
fuck out myself on TV.
When I was 19 I was in the bay state
games and taekwondo tournament in there.
I heard myself on TV and it was so bad.
I,
I immediately got rid of the accent
and figured out how to get it out.
Yeah,
I had had it.
I had it.
It was pretty deep.
We've been working really
hard and I was like,
oh my God.
I listen to myself.
I was like,
what the fuck is sort of like a mix
between an American and British and
something else?
It's really strange,
but I'm,
I'm,
I,
I love,
I like movies where they
have the Boston accent,
but it's fucking hot
accent to try to replicate.
Yeah.
It's people fuck it up all the time.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's a tricky one.
It's an interesting,
it's a fun accent.
It's like it's a good accent to have.
If you here,
if you're out,
if you're drinking and you're around
a bunch of guys at Boston accents,
I guarantee you they're
going to be funnier.
That that's probably the funniest group
of humans per capita is Boston men.
You know,
it's hard life up there,
man.
Women are ugly.
It's cold as fuck.
Women are ugly and Boston
monsters really monsters.
Women in Texas,
it's like I said,
it's not their fault.
It's six.
This is hot women.
It wasn't dealt with the hottest.
Texans have the nicest Americans too.
I think it takes us to just
really polite and you got it.
You're,
you're,
you're only dealing with city,
Texas.
There's a different,
there's a different
Texas chainsaw massacre,
Texas,
and you've got to go out into the way
you got to go to Jasper where they drag
black people behind trucks
showing it that there's a,
yeah,
there's Meth,
Texas.
Okay,
I'll rephrase it to Dallas,
Texas.
I love like,
Oh,
Rephrase Dallas.
Texas is the shit.
This skill,
when I say y'all to like
San Antonio and Houston,
Houston is amazing.
Austin is one of my favorite cities
of all tossed and apparently everyone
autotune.
It's like one of the most
best cities in America.
Yeah.
It's incredible.
The guy there,
but there's,
you know,
there's outside of that,
the problem as you drive outside
of that a half an hour and you're,
you're in fucking Roscoe p Coltrane.
Coltrane,
yeah,
yeah.
It gets,
it's squirrely.
Texas is real squirrely and they got it.
The real conservative laws and they,
you know,
they can fuck you up over reefer.
Anything.
Traps everywhere.
Guy was telling me that make my day law,
we can shoot fucked.
Someone that comes into your house,
you not only can shoot
somebody comes in your house,
you could shoot someone who's
trying to repossess your car.
Yup.
They've had people who shot people who
they thought were trying to steal their
car,
shot him with a rifle.
It turns out was a repo guy.
It turned out that he
was vindicated and guide.
Never did any time at all.
Really?
I shot a guy with a fucking deer hunting
rifle that was just trying to do his
job and repossess the car.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
You're a car thief.
You know?
That's how they look at it.
It's like some true,
even though the repo guy is doing,
is legal,
you know,
the bank is repossessing its property
and the hardest guy to do it.
What the shooter is doing is legal too,
because you didn't represent
yourself as a repo man.
And even if you did,
even if he did,
he might be able to shoot you.
So it's not true though,
that if you shoot any true to it,
you have to kill them.
No,
it's not true.
I'm just going to shoot him.
I mean,
you don't have to even shoot.
there's no law like it's like a deer.
You know?
Someone told me,
I just got you shoot them.
You get to Mike show you killed him.
Otherwise I can see you for shooting them.
Well,
I bet they could.
Yeah,
So not necessarily whether they would
win would they could probably take you
through the system.
Yeah,
you,
but if you did shoot them and kill them,
it wouldn't know.
Then they can't see.
You obviously know that,
but it wouldn't be,
you wouldn't be charged for manslaughter.
You know,
people who've gotten in trouble in Texas
for shooting their wife and boyfriend
and gotten away with it.
Really?
Yeah.
It's like this is a crime of passion.
You come home,
some guys banging your wife
and you fucking shoot him.
You know,
you can get away with that.
There's,
there's some tricky shit that
you can get away with Texas.
You know?
I don't know if it's a
concealed carry state.
I don't know if it is.
I don't know if you're allowed to like
go wild west style and have had all
fucking Holston lister is in some
places you're not allowed to do that,
but you are allowed to
carry it out in the open.
So if you have like a handgun,
you just allowed to hold it out in the
open as you walk towards the supermarket.
Like what the fuck man,
you know,
imagine you know you're going to
the supermarket and some dude,
it's just walking with his gun out in
the open because that's how the law is.
The law states that at the
sand coming to America,
I admit a care is indeed.
What did you think about this whole a
Norway thing that just went down with this
one guy?
I'm just getting all the
information yet opened up at a camp,
a children's cancer,
a huge amount of children.
I mean I don't know how many it's going
to be all told cause there's a lot of
injuries and some of these
kids are going to die,
but it's over 80 kids I believe and know
is one of those countries that flies
under the radar.
And you'd never hear shit from Norway.
Nothing bad ever comes out
of nowhere on my buddy Doug.
Stan hope just filmed his last DVD there.
Oslo where this,
all this happened now and there's one guy,
some crazy.
All they're saying is he's
very religious and you know,
and,
and anti Muslim I believe,
but that's who knows,
who knows how much they even know about
what the fuck the real situation is.
It's,
you know,
it's,
the dust is still settling.
What a horrible,
horrible fire hoses this paper to do.
This is,
it just,
the thing is just being fucking pure evil.
Just you're fucking evil.
You know,
who knows man,
you know?
Did you ever see the,
the man who a shot,
there was a woman who was a congressman
shutting the place where the head or
whatever?
Yes.
She lived deferred and then,
you know,
he killed a bunch of
people also on the scene.
That guy had a bunch of videos that
he had put on Youtube and written some
things and it was just,
he was obviously,
his brain wasn't working right.
He had like his,
like he would make these who say these
things are just like would they would
call word salad?
Just throw a bunch of words together.
It didn't make any sense.
Like there was obviously
a disconnect if he was,
it was functioning incorrectly.
And look,
the,
the human mind is a very complicated
instrument and sometimes it's,
it,
it's fucked up and sometimes it's,
it's off.
Just like some people get cancer
and some people get diseases,
some people's brains don't.
Some people have some fucking balls
watching his TV show with this guy had a
fetish for vomit hills quarter.
Uh,
uh,
it's off the Greek word for vomit.
I should have asked Irene,
but as a finish of his,
and the only way he could get
hard was when chicks vomited.
So he wouldn't pay prostitutes
to spew on him and vomit.
And if you went to a restaurant
and he saw someone chuck,
he would go and scoop the chuck
up and put her in a plastic bag.
And I took the camera inside this giant
freezer that he'd stored all these bags
of vomit from over the years.
And he had each one of
the bags like documented,
so he was grabbing a bag off the off.
They were frozen,
frozen.
He'd grab it,
right?
He's like,
oh yeah,
Taco Bell,
1992 she fucking blew chunks in the
floor like a fucking get turned on.
Just thinking about it a minute,
a midnight and midnight,
midnight.
So fucking finish for people fucking
chucking up and Gil spewing on it.
The only way he could get an erection
if a hooker or a friend of his,
would you pay them to stick their fingers
down their throat and check up on him?
Why don't,
yeah,
like how the fuck do you explain that?
Like also these dudes,
dudes,
they called feeders and
they feed those fat chicks.
The little skinny.
Have you seen that feeders?
There's something on a TV show.
I saw a show again,
we've got this,
he has some crazy shit on TV here.
These little skinny fucking dude's.
It looked like the 45 to 50
kilos in weight and has the,
what is that in pounds?
Pounds higher.
10 pounds.
110 hundred and 20 pounds,
right?
They have these wives or girlfriends
who are fucking behemoths,
like 300 pound Emanuel,
Yarbrough looking fucking women who lie
in bed all day and immobilized because
they're so huge.
The cat really fucking move and then
little men feed and the little men feed
them.
They're called feeders and they get off
sexually on feeding these women and just
constantly fucking feeding them and
give them these women fucking fat.
I can't say I'm surprised.
I'm surprised.
I would have been surprised if you told
me that 20 years ago if you told me that
before I knew about the Internet,
I'd be like flat.
They can really,
I would say that doesn't
even make any sense.
Why would somebody,
and maybe one person's into that,
this other dude on the show,
online community on this.
I,
no,
apparently it's like the,
I won't say a popular thing,
but it's like a thing.
There's like a feeder community and
fucking skinny dudes are feeding these
chicks.
Just feeding them constantly
sitting by the bedside.
Fucking someone needs.
When those people become immobile
and they can't even leave the house,
who think,
well,
that's the perfect time to go on a diet.
You can't even move.
How long would it take to starve
someone like that to death?
If you just gave him water,
they have so much fat.
Precious.
The fact wouldn't pay for a
wall more than a normal person.
You would die of starvation still.
Even if you were there,
that would cause your stomach
would start shrinking.
There's extra to happen.
You give them water rights.
They're staying hydrated.
Yeah.
If you just gave him water and
how nobody started building,
I don't know.
That's what I'm saying.
Don't try to efficient.
I don't think it can just like use
it as an alternative fuel supply,
but then again,
they're not using up any food for energy
because they're just fucking lying
there.
They need some just to
pump blood and breathe air.
They need,
they need some energy.
I don't think it's possible.
I mean,
I think,
I mean I'm,
no,
it's not possible.
I know you would starve to death
even if you're a big fat fuck,
but I wonder how many days it would last.
I wonder if you would last like
if you had like a lean guy,
you know like you get like a fucking cow,
King's super athlete,
lean guy and you put them in a room with
some job of the Hautelook and stop them
both.
Who would die first?
Who would die from?
It's interesting.
You would think the fat guy would have
at least a little bit more energy.
How's the little guy fuck the fat chick?
How does everyone find the
pussy to probably does?
It probably does.
It probably just fucking tosses off beat.
It's somebody who likes him,
you know there's some people out there
that are just happy than anybody likes
them.
They'll take anybody broken.
It's probably doesn't.
There was a woman who died who
was like grafted into a couch.
She was slowly,
her skin was starting to graft itself to
the couch and when they cut her out of
the house,
they had cut a hole in the wall
to pull her out of the house.
And when they cut her out,
they had to cut her out with the couch.
Fuck yeah.
And then she died of complications.
Fuck,
that's crazy,
man.
Yeah.
Well,
you know what,
there's,
like I said,
there's a broad spectrum.
People can go off the fucking dignity,
dignity,
deep end in many different ways.
This other dude on the show had an
obsession that he wanted to return to the
womb.
Oh whoa.
And he's wife was pregnant and he was
jealous of his unborn child for being in
his wife's womb.
And he said,
did his thing,
was he,
he had an obsession with
needing to return to the womb.
Can imagine that poor woman have to
deal with that bitch bitch of a man.
And that's the one who's
fathering your children.
Some fucking freak,
Weirdo fetishes climb back inside fucking
uterus so he doesn't have to deal with
it anymore.
Cause he's life is all learn.
And would it be a BB Gabey Limo me
through me and be saved back in the little
house in the prayer.
He didn't believe it.
Crazy assholes.
Fucking ridiculous.
While we live in extreme times and
you and I traveled in the most extreme
circles,
you know,
if you really think about it,
the cage fighting commentary
and kickboxing commentary
flying all over the world
and being around all these savages and,
and yet we're still shocked by the
level of human behavior out there in the
world.
Let's try and use that like I don't
get shocked by the volunt knockouts.
I seen the crazy cuts and
the blood and the sea,
but did you think that when you
were in that fight with that dude,
that dude was coming out?
You just think like,
wow,
I'm just so used to conflict and so
used to fight that it's like it's even
though you're not getting in them,
you probably were way more calm than an
average dude because you're so used to
being around fun just seed.
Mine is just,
it's there.
It's always in your face.
Okay,
Betty,
you sing it at the highest level,
the lowest level.
You just sing it such just,
it's almost programmed into you HC nuts.
Got To step it up,
dude.
[inaudible] got to figure out some way
to get on more TVs because they fucking,
the programming is awesome.
You know the,
the shells that they have as awesome
as the only place to get high level
kickboxing in America.
It is.
You never see it and we're doing it.
Showtime down there shows a fantastic man,
showtime or this one coming up in May.
You?
Yeah,
they actually pay you that pie.
One man.
Is Caitlin going to fold and it's
showtime got to take over cause I've heard
that.
I don't think so.
I'm told the k one will survive,
but in what capacity?
I'm not sure.
Not that it showed Tom will take over,
but it showed time's going to be the
one to watch this and Mark Cuban's a bad
motherfucker.
Okay.
He owns the God damn world champion.
Dallas Mavericks brought
them along to that title,
owns Hca.
Tell him to step the fuck up.
And by k one it's
probably like 1000 bucks.
You could break by k one for their debt.
I actually heard about
a year and a half ago,
but the price tag for
k one was $30 million.
It's gotta be less than that now,
I believe.
Say Yeah.
Well you know that they bought
the UFC for like 2 million,
but if you bought k one
for even 10 million bucks,
man,
dude,
Mark Cuban could turn k
one and two a Munster.
Fuck.
You take the same level of talent,
the real high end guys,
they have now at k one Max and,
and the the the k one Grand Prix,
the heavyweight Grand Prix and put those
on in Vegas and make a big fucking deal
out of it.
Maybe the prison or never at all.
Dana,
what the fuck out Mark Cuban please?
We're begging you.
Step the fuck up.
There's an opening to be had here.
There's some product to be sold.
This is a fucking strong possibility.
You can make it happen.
Mark Cuban.
Um,
all right,
this is a long fucking podcast.
It's hours,
hours.
Fuck.
Uh,
this week I'm going to have
Jay Moore on the podcast.
We're figuring out when to do it.
I've got to call Jay back.
He's doing this thing with Kevin Smith
and we're trying to bring awareness to
that.
He's got a new podcast of his own.
He,
Kevin should be sitting in his seat.
No,
he,
I only did it hit his ass chemistry.
I love him too.
You have to seat though.
That's beautiful.
Yeah,
he's a great guy.
Um,
he's doing so Jay Morris doing something
like Kevin Smith and network of
podcasts and he's also going to do some
sort of a television thing with Kevin
Smith,
so he's got that going on.
But Jay and I are going
to do a podcast soon.
This week we got Giorgio
sucralose from ancient aliens.
He's going to be on the podcast.
We got a lot of stuff happening and we're
also looking at the new studio space
this week.
We've got to figure out
a new place to do this.
I'm moving on up folks.
We've got to step up.
We're going to,
we're going to also
produce a Joey d as DVD.
That's another thing that
we've just decided to do.
So that's all for now.
Uh,
September 21st in Denver.
At the paramount theater.
I got also a coming up,
uh,
the PAPP's theater in
Milwaukee sometimes soon.
I'm not sure when that is.
I don't have my thing in front of me,
but it's soon.
All right.
And Yeah,
Pap smear theater,
the PAPP's theater,
Pabst,
Pabst brewing company.
Oh,
August 13th in Milwaukee.
Um,
so,
uh,
if you want to talk to
Mike and contact him,
you can get him on Twitter
at Shia velo voice.
That's s c h a v e l l o,
voice on,
on Twitter.
And you have Chevelle,
voice.com to no,
just your belly Bush on
Twitter and on Facebook.
Do you have a website?
Just he's hd.website.
Yeah,
that's definitely kick,
kick in and get a fucking,
she avail voice dot Connie
to get one to come on,
man.
Get in there.
All right dude.
Thank you very much Brian
and podcast always man.
Always good.
And so,
uh,
Michael and I are going to kick back
and we're going to have a barbecue.
Now,
ladies and gentlemen,
that's the end of this show.
And thank you very much for tuning
in and thank you to the fleshlight.
And if you go to [inaudible],
she don't get crazy.
Your wife's here,
Bro.
Uh,
go to,
uh,
Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight
and enter in the code name Rogan,
and you will get 15% off.
And then you could shoot all
your loads at a discount.
You Go,
oh,
that feels good.
And I saved money.
All right,
so you got you on.
Bye.
Love you bitches.
My Bot.